[Music]
what is this see here's the thing dude
you don't even know Curtis from from top
boy season 2 ktis ktis ktis I no I don't
but I know that [__] anytime there's any
sort of screenshot of audio messages you
know it's going to be [__] hysterical
that thing always yeah that [__] be
squirting and F and F that's what we got
there let's go let's go this is this is
actually
genuinely the ending of this is going to
[__] you up okay can't wait in a bad
way to the story because I'm literally
telling everyone it's so horrific so my
friend Amilia who I was with yesterday
she's got a mate called Ellie who's in a
house share in London what did you just
say what so I've got M Ellie who lives
in LLY and she's in in and
the house share in London I know I'm
just saying like the way the accent hits
all right let me not make fun of her to
the story because I'm literally telling
everyone it's so horrific so my friend
Amilia who I was with yesterday she's
got a mate called Ellie who's in a house
share in London and um Ellie shares with
like a bunch of girls and one of the
girls was telling her she's just been on
a Hindu to Amsterdam where hu that's a
bachelor party yeah stag and the hen
went at the same time I think they were
just like a mixed social group who kind
of like knew each other but then the
Stag went one day and the hen one way
and the hens went the other one of the
girls on the henu got super drunk and
went into one of these boobs with like a
glory hole and so a GU on the other side
stuck his dick through so the girl was
just drunk and started sucking him off
what a casual yeah in America in America
we'd be like so they think they hooked
her or like she gave him like head or
something yeah yeah yeah so she goes
into the booth and a guy sticks his
cocking balls in there and she just
starts sucking them off spitting on it
you know the whole nine yeah yeah but it
was one of these ones apparently where
like if like he pushes a button and the
guy pushes the button on the other side
they can kind of see who's on the other
side like it makes it like transparent
like a window so they can see so anyway
I H I hit the [__] button and it's my
boy it's my mate he's just completely
finished
me I'm getting sucked off and I hit the
I push the button and lo and behold and
it's I've just finished on callum's face
yeah and I say o Gea I say oh you
[__] oh you DFT [__] what the [__]
are you doing over there and it's just
Calum on his knees smiling picking it
he's like oh man I just finished you off
I haven't
oh man you just comed on me
neck you've just cumbed on us you oh M
you've just comed on us being drunk she
thought it'd be hilarious to push this
button just to see who you've been
sucking
off
okay naturally as you do you know I'm in
a glory hole might as well see who I'm
getting yeah you got to see who you're
sucking that's what I always say and so
pushes the button and looks up and it's
her dad on the other
side and apparently like the hen and the
Stag do all went home early because it
was like so traumatic and the girl's
falling out with all her family the
mom's obviously found out and is like
not speaking to the dad like it's broken
up the whole family because this girl
sucked off her dad through a glory
hole what an ending
line what an ending line that's [__]
dark Jesus Christ that's really dark I'm
sorry did I I kid CTI it no no no it's
it's fine I mean it is really funny like
you
know it's really dark though
Jesus
Christ [__] I mean the dad shouldn't
have been in a [__] glory hole Yeah
it's his fault
yeah maybe we don't dwell on this long
enough cuz when you when you think about
stuff then it's yeah you know yeah I
know I just showed everyone like you
know their parents having sex basically
like the equivalent of
like it does make you think like every
time it does make you think like every
time now that every time after this that
I'm in a glory hole sucking someone off
I'm going to wonder who
it I'm going to wonder who it is oh man
you know what I mean me I wonder who's
on the other side of this [__] hole
traditionally I never think about it
usually I just keep the button off but
now I'm just like yeah yeah now I'm
going to like that's going to really
weigh on me yeah Fu man it's really
funny ruin glory for me it's really
funny to like [__] with someone with
with that button like you just flash it
for a second you just
[Laughter]
eyes just moving around the
room that'd be really funny stop you
stop sucking but you're like up at the
face level and you hit it and you're
like
yeah oh you grab his dick
simultaneously got your dick got your
dick
wait you close it then you turn it back
on you have all your friends in there
pointing and
laughing just for one
second ah wait whoa hey hey or like you
unfogging it just a flash from a
camera looking right at a
phone dude that's so bad good morning
yeah yeah unog it again damn
dude damn or just weird [__] they just
turn on the light and just got to dude
gaming back
there
yeah why'd you stick your dick in that
hole man yeah yeah it just showed
different scenes yeah oh that'd be
hilarious your dick's just pointed in
like a [__] Subway walkway people
walking
by the hell that's good yeah that is
good or it's a
mirror and the dick is like there's like
a mustache on it and some eyes ah yeah
yeah yeah
nice or you just you turn on the light
and it's a group of dudes in there are
cheering on their guy do it do it is
that a glory
hole there's nothing quite like a juicy
Ted in the morning oh man that's [__]
up dude sorry let's read some replies I
feel bad bringing that one up no no I'm
glad you did who's in the wrong
wow that's brutal who's in the wrong in
the wrong oh no they unfogged the glass
into Band Saw
coming moving in yeah you unfogged the
glass you just got a pitbull there yeah
yeah oh my God and you're just like
you're just drizzling [__] yeah
you're just drizzling like red red meat
this is just saw yeah let's play a
game